-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian
you know from her work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
which returns this week
live on NBC and Peacock,
with host Dakota Johnson
and musical guest
Justin Timberlake.
Please welcome to the show
Punkie Johnson, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, Punkie.
-What's up, y'all?
What's up, Seth?
How you doing?
I'm happy to be here.
-I appreciate you making time
on a Tuesday.
I know what a busy day it is.
-Oh, absolutely.
We got Write Night tonight.
-You got a writing night
tonight?
It's gonna be a long night.
-Yes, it is.
I have heard this story that
early in your time at "SNL,"
you actually, uh -- you kind of
pulled a power move.
There was somebody who could not
get into the "SNL" afterparty.
-Oh, yeah. [ Laughs ]
-And we have a photo.
And This is Travis Kelce.
They would not let him in.
-Right, right, right, right,
right.
-Now, what really happened?
Is it true that at the door
they just didn't know
who Travis was?
-The crazy thing is,
he had came to the show.
We saw him at the show.
And then he goes
to the afterparty,
and he's just looking.
And I was like,
"Oh, that's Travis Kelce."
And they're sitting up there --
they're like,
"You can't get in, bro.
You're not on the list."
And I'm sitting up there like,
"Why isn't he
listing his résumé?
'Cause I'm on 'SNL.'
I'm, like, D-list celebrity."
I would have been
like, "I'm on 'SNL'!
I know Lorne Michaels!"
[ Laughter ]
But he was just sitting up
there, just being so innocent,
like, "Oh, my God,
should I call someone?"
So I went over there,
and I was like,
"This is a Super Bowl champion!
He is daggone the greatest
tight end in the daggone NFL!"
I was saying everything
he should have said.
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"He's on my list!
Come on, Travis!"
[ Laughter ]
And -- And then
I guess we became,
like, friends.
I made him take pict--
Well, forceful friends.
I'm like, "You're gonna
take pictures with me
every time you see me."
-Yep.
-"I'm gonna be
heavily a part of your life.
We're having children
together.
Like, "You owe me for this party
forever, bro."
-That would have been
very embarrassing.
This is a very cool picture.
If it had just been him standing
outside a party, very lame.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Uh, what --
I always like to ask,
where were you
when you got the call
that you were hired on "SNL"?
-Oh, man.
So, it was very shaky.
You know, this job, they be
playing a lot of mind games.
-They do that.
-They like,
"We gonna call you on --"
They're like,
"Lorne Michaels is gonna
call you on a Friday..."
-Uh-huh.
-"...if you got the job."
Friday done came and gone.
Lorne ain't calling.
I'm like, "I ain't get the job."
They called me Saturday morning,
"Alright,
he gonna call you today
for sure if you got the job."
Lorne ain't call.
I'm like, "I ain't got the job."
So, Sunday is Tom Brady
is playing his first game
in the NFC with the Bucs...
-Yeah.
-,,,against my team,
New Orleans Saints.
And I'm like -- Drew Brees
is giving it to him, too.
I'm like, "Yeah,
we run the NFC!"
And it's a big old family party.
We so excited.
I'm drinking, I'm --
you know I'm celebrating
the fact that I got that far
in the audition process.
I'm like, "I didn't make it.
Whatever."
And then, as I'm taking a shot,
Lorne calls.
[ Laughter ]
By this point,
I'm like, "Oh, God."
You know what I'm saying?
So, I answer the phone.
I'm like, "Hey!
Yes, this is Punkie. Hi!"
And then he has this
long conversation with me.
I don't know what
he's talking about,
'cause I'm in a trance
at this moment,
trying to figure out how
to not let this man know
I've been drinking,
watching Drew Brees
beat up on Tom Brady.
And, um, at the end
of the conversation,
he's like, "Yo,
come be on the cast.
You got the job."
I'm like, "Yo, what's up?"
Then he said,
"Oh, pack your bags.
You leave tomorrow."
I'm like, "It's 6:00 p.m."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "What kind of job..."
-You were like,
"I'm gonna start celebrating."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Your, mom, Mary,
who was on the show.
-Yeah. Yeah yeah yeah,
yeah, yeah.
-A lovely picture
of you and your mom.
And when you packed those bags
to come to New York City,
she put a couple of pictures
in your suitcase,
with a couple of notes.
-[ Laughs ]
She put some pictures
and some notes.
Pictures of us and, like,
stuff, like, you know,
"We proud of you.
You made it.
'Live from New York,
it's Punkie Johnson!'"
All that stuff. Yeah, cute.
And then under that, um,
[Chuckles] --
under that, she was like,
"But I got an invoice
of all the money you owe me
from the time you was born."
[ Laughter ]
"And now is the time for you
to start paying me back.
You finally -- You finally
on the road to recovery."
I'm like -- She's like,
"You owe me for your life."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like,
"I ain't asked to be here.
How do I owe you?"
But --
-She's gotten used
to the finer things?
-She has. I've been taking --
She's been fine-dining.
I've been putting her
on first class
all around the world now.
Now she bougie.
[ Laughter ]
She's mad bougie.
So now, like,
she called me one time,
I was getting her
to come out here to New York,
and it was on a specific date,
and she was like,
"Unh-unh,
they only got comfort.
'Cause everything was sold out.
I was like, "Well, Ma,
you got to ride comfort,
because I need shoes."
Like, "I'm gonna have
to come the day after
or the day before, because..."
[ Laughter ]
"this comfort --
this three-row seat stuff
ain't gonna work for me."
[ Laughter ]
-She got used to it.
-I mean, you know,
once you get them accustomed
to a certain way of life,
you got to keep it rolling.
-Now you have a
less-than-bougie ritual
after the afterparty.
-Oh. Super trashy, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But everybody think it's trashy,
and I don't.
After every "SNL" party,
I got to hit up some Taco Bell.
-Okay.
I gotta do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, the "SNL" party
will move around.
The afterparty
is different every week.
Do you then know the locations
of the closest Taco Bell
when you're leaving?
-So, I be a little bit
under the weather intoxicatedly,
so my driver
always knows the location.
-Great. That's good.
-My driver always know.
"Taco Bell?"
I'm like, "Taco Bell.
You know what's going on."
So I go to Taco Bell.
The people at Taco Bell know me.
I be -- I be tipping them.
[ Laughter ]
Because I always go
with an entourage,
and it's always
some foolishness.
I'm like, "Man, take this 50,
my dawg,"
and it be all good.
-That's good.
You've done a lot of
really great musical things
on the show.
-Yeah.
-You did a wonderful rap
with Keke Palmer.
And rapping was actually
something you were gonna
pursue back in the day.
-Ha-ha!
-You have yourself a rap name.
-I did. I sucked.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-But, [Chuckles] I mean,
I thought I was good at rapping
until I heard other rappers,
and I was like,
"Nah, let me -- let me
just stick to being goofy."
[ Laughter ]
So, my rap name was J. Willy.
It wasn't even hard.
It was just, you know,
just it was just goofy.
So I was like, "Nah, just go be
a comedian, bro. You good."
-Well, I'm glad you made
the choice you did.
It has been a fantastic season
for you so far.
And it's been great
having you here tonight.
Thank you so much.
-Absolutely.
Thank y'all so much,
-That's Punkie Johnson.
"SNL"returns this week,
live on NBC and Peacock,
with host Dakota Johnson,
musical guest Justin Timberlake.
We'll be right back
with Brad Meltzer.